- [Instructor] Hello readers.
Today I'm in a courthouse,
watching people argue about laws,
so we can learn about
the power of Evidence.
Evidence is essentially proof,
it is the facts that help you
know that something is true,
Let's listen in.
- [Male] And Your Honor,
that is why we propose that
cookies be made illegal.
The prosecution rests.
- [Judge] Mmh, very interesting indeed.
- [Woman] Objection, Your Honor.
I may be a simple country
lawyer, but even I can see
that my opponent has neglected to offer up
a single crumb of evidence,
in favor of banning all cookies,
undefeated and offensive
anti-cookie slogans.
- [Judge] Objection sustained.
You will give evidence for your claims,
or I will dismiss this
case in favor of cookies.
You have not yet proved that cookies
pose a threat to public health.
Show me where it says in our books of law
that I even have the
right to make this ruling.
Both of you are going to
need to give me Evidence.
- [Instructor] Okay, so you can see
that there were a couple
of things happening here.
There's a group of people
who wanna keep cookies,
a group of people who wanna ban cookies,
and in the middle of it a judge
who has to decide which
group of people is right.
So, she asked them for Evidence.
If you believe cookies are
bad, what's your proof?
If you believe cookies
are good in moderation,
what's your proof?
Let's step out of the
courtroom for a second
and go to this example in a text.
- [Man] I'm in big trouble.
I forgot to do the social
studies project last weekend!
In my defense, I did have
a very unusual weekend.
My stepdad Zeke unexpectedly picked me up
from school last Friday,
because he got free tickets
to the Dodgers game.
Then, since the game got
over late, we decided
to stay at my grandma's house,
because she lives sort of by the stadium.
In the morning she asked if
we could paint her garage.
Of course we did, but it took all day.
On Sunday, I'm sorry to report,
I devoted my entire day
to watching Voltron.
Let's try answering some questions
that require us to look back
at the text for evidence.
This is like the bedrock
of any kind of writing.
If you make a claim, you have
to back it up with evidence.
So, did the author remember to do
their social studies project last weekend?
No. And why do we know that?
They say so in the very first line,
I forgot to do the social studies project.
Okay, that's easy mode, you're saying.
Fine, what did the author of
this piece do on Saturday?
You'll notice the word Saturday
doesn't appear in the paragraphs above,
and yet I could tell you with confidence
and to direct support from the text, how?
Well, let's go back and look at the text.
My stepdad Zeke unexpectedly picked me up
from school last Friday,"
and we keep reading,
Then since the game got over late,
we decided to stay at my grandma's house
because she sort of lives by the stadium.
So the author and their
stepdad spent the night
Friday night at grandma's house.
The story continues,
In the morning she, the grandma,
asked if we could paint her garage.
Of course we did, but it took all day.
Which morning?
Saturday morning!
I'm pulling information
directly out of the text
to support my answer.
The author spent Saturday,
painting their grandmother's garage.
Oh, hold on, let's head
back to the courthouse.
I think the judge is
ready to issue her verdict
and decide the case.
(hammering)
- [Judge] This court will
come to order, please, Order!
Thank you.
We've heard the arguments
of the prosecution
and the defense, both anti
cookie and pro cookie.
And now the time has
come to give my judgment.
The anti cookie side presented
a very interesting case,
showing the effects of
cookie exposure to teeth
and the dangerous effects
of having too much sugar
and feeling all wibbly
but the pro cookie side also
gave very compelling evidence,
showing that in moderation,
a cookie can be a very tasty snack indeed,
provided that you treat
them for what they are,
something to have every so often,
this court finds in favor of the cookie.
(hammering)
Thank you.
- [Instructor] Wow readers.
I think we just witnessed
something important and historic.
And it couldn't have happened
without the power of evidence.
You can learn anything Dave it out.
(indistinct chattering)